[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici
les titres le point sur l'initiative
génération lully avec hervé bourquel
deux thèmes le directeur général du
centre de musique baroque
l'opération permet aux habitants de
trappes de découvrir la musique baroque
française
et puis les ventes passent était ce week
end à la batterie de bus en cours pour
un concert punk et rock
nous en avons profité pour interviewer
didier wampas le fondateur du groupe
présent sur la scène française depuis
une trentaine d'années la musique
baroque pour tous c'est la mission de
génération lully une action culturelle
menée par le centre de musique baroque
de versailles en partenariat avec la
ville de trappes pour en savoir plus
écoutez le directeur général du centre
de musique baroque
hervé burck f2 tél au micro de camille
lambert depuis septembre le centre de
musique baroque de versailles s'est
lancé dans un projet génération lully
une action culturelle qui se déroule à
la trappe
et pour en savoir plus nous sommes avec
hervé bourquel de tels directeur général
du centre de musique baroque bonjour
hervé bonjour alors ce projet génération
lui mais j'ai parlé d'actions
culturelles mais plus concrètement
qu'est ce que c'est il s'agit d'une
action éducative et culturelle en effet
qui se déroule à trappes pendant trois
années 2016 2017 et 2018 et qui a pour
objectif de travailler et de de
sensibiliser d'abord toutes les
générations
d'où le terme génération lully les
générations qui le souhaitent donc de
trappes à la musique baroque française
autour du fondateur de la musique
française qu'est jean baptiste lully
d'où le nom sur d'où le nom génération
du lit alors pourquoi la ville de
trappes qu'est ce qui a motivé ce choix
de
ce choix de population de raisons pour
cela la première c'est que nous avions
déjà en 2013 et 2014
mené un premier projet culturel éducatif
et culturel à trappes dans le cadre de
l'anniversaire rameau l'époque ce
n'était pas lui lit donc mais rameau
deuxième très grand compositeur delà de
la musique baroque française et nous
avions mené un projet un atelier de
création avec les jeunes des
établissements scolaires de la ville de
trappes
à l'époque déjà pourquoi trappe tout
simplement parce que nous sommes deux
villes très proche distance kilomètres
je crois nous séparent et dans une
première approche tout nous oppose une
ville historique une ville plus récente
une ville qualifiées de bourgeoise une
ville avec une population beaucoup plus
diverse un grand château à versailles
rien de tel à trappes et dans le même
temps bien entendu des populations qui
ont des choses à faire ensemble qui pour
lesquelles il est important d'ailleurs
que des choses se fassent ensemble et
ç'avait été une grande réussite c'est à
dire nous avions fait un spectacle très
je crois très réussie tant sur le plan
éducatif que sur le plan artistique et
qui avait été présenté au théâtre de la
merise puis à l'opéra royal du château
de versailles
fort de l'expérience de 2014 le centre
de musique baroque de versailles qu'on
appelle plus communément le cmbv a été
jumelée avec la ville de trappes
la grande différence c'est que nous
travaillons avec des populations
beaucoup plus diverse que le seul public
scolaire nous travaillons avec les
établissements scolaires mais également
avec le tissu associatif de la ville de
trappes et enfin les structures
municipales qui dépendent directement de
la ville de trappes
alors ce que pouvait justement donner
des exemples de ces actions nous avons
suivi la création du spectacle être sans
folie avec l'école de la deuxième chance
de trappes également des ateliers de
costumes création de costumes alors
comment ce que ça s'organise en fait
qu'est ce qui lie à d'autres comme
atelier alors ça prend en effet plaints
de forme
ce sont des visites du château de
versailles suivi par exemple
d'audition de notre maîtrise les pages
les chambres du centre de musique
baroque de versailles cmbv tous les
jeudis ça passe par des visites du cmbv
ça passe par des halles inverse des
interventions des artistes dans les
associations et les établissements
scolaires
et ça passe par la préparation et le
fait d'assister à des productions qui
ont été montés par le cmv et cette année
nous en avions deux qui étaient
particulièrement pertinente dans le
cadre d'un l'ensemble d'un projet autour
de lully la deuxième production le
deuxième projet ce sont donc les c'est
donc par dans la parodie pour
marionnettes chanteurs et musiciens
d'athis à tisser l'opéra sans doute le
plus connu de jean baptiste lully et une
parodie a été recréée qui s'appelle donc
atys en folie ce projet a été créé à
malte est d'ailleurs de jeunes
stagiaires de l'école de la deuxième
chance nous ont accompagnés à malte pour
assister à cette création pour être dans
les coulisses en quelque sorte de cette
création est le projet dans le cadre de
génération lui lui a été immédiatement
de redonner cette production attrape le
2 mars
ça donne aussi des idées de métier au
delà au delà de la découverte de la
musique baroque c'est aussi la
découverte de différents métiers
caustique mais auquel on ne pense pas
forcément c'est la découverte d'un
milieu en quelque sorte de je suppose de
découvrir que la musique ce sont des
musiciens et je crois qu'il ya un grand
intérêt des stagiaires dans les
rencontres qu'ils ont pu table qu'ils
ont pu avoir avec les musiciens mais
également voir qu'il ya des
marionnettistes des décorateur
scénographe des régisseurs qui
travaillent autour d'une production de
ce type
et en effet ça donne des ouvertures à
chacun d'entre eux en tout cas de
réelles découvertes par exemple
prochainement un stagiaire de l'école de
la deuxième chance viendra au cmbv en
régie et on a beaucoup parlé de cette
année de sensibilisation qui a lieu
actuellement et l'an prochain sera une
année de création
alors qu'est ce que c'est c'est d'entrer
dans une deuxième action qui est l
active
ou vraiment un certain nombre de jeunes
et de moins jeunes deviennent acteurs
d'un spectacle
donc l'idée pendant cette deuxième année
c'est de créer un spectacle autour de
jean baptiste lully qui est à écrire un
spectacle qui sera écrit spécialement et
coécrit j'allais dire aussi avec les
professeurs avec un certain nombre
d'associations et ce spectacle auquel
participeront des acteurs des chanteurs
des danseurs mais aussi auquel seront
associés des jeunes et des moins jeunes
qui pourront participer justement à
l'élaboration de la scénographie à sa
régie sera présenté en mai 2018 au
théâtre de la merise attrape et ensuite
déboucher un peu plus prestigieux en
termes de salles à l'opéra royal du
château de versailles donc à noter dès
maintenant pour nos téléspectateurs de
rendez vous à noter
merci beaucoup et revues merci à vannes
il y à 34 ans débarqué sur la scène punk
rock française un ovni les wampas 34 ans
plus tard ils sont toujours là avec à
leur tête un certain didier le groupe
était ce week end à la batterie de bus
en cours avec les titres de leur nouvel
album
véronique ithurbide et patrick jacques
de dixmude ont rencontré le fondateur du
groupe pour nous
[Musique]
m
et moi j'ai juste et c'est qui c'est un
album c'est nom de l'album c'est non
ajoute heures de cette phrase est à 7 en
juillet et au mois d'août il ya là à la
saint-jean il ya une grande fête
les joutes sétoises sur ce je ne sais
pas un bateau wake des rameurs et des
genres des jouteurs avec des lances ces
deux sur tombé à l'eau ça sent comme ça
il ya tout tout un folklore tous
tenaient les gens evangelisti c'était un
peu une légende des joutes il a gagné
5,6 fois sa bonhommie fait 200 kg et
estaing exhibe le mans voulais pas
qu'ils gagnent on l'a éliminée
ajustements et j'étais là où la révolte
et je suis déjà plus l'album evangelisti
pour le venger et les potins du gros
temps il au courant ouais bah oui quand
même
ouais génial un club de soi qu'il
ouvrait son avis si tu le croise dans
les rues de sète mais qui n'est pas
content oui oui ça peut faire mal
d'accord dans cet album ouais mais bon
j'ai dit il ya plusieurs chansons un
petit peu énigmatique
selon va souvent souvent tous les
diables oui oui il y en a qui sont cons
comprend reprend le thème il y en a
d'autres
on se pose des questions alors ce petit
garçon roux l'a traumatisé c'est quoi
cette histoire j'ai par contre plusieurs
dimensions chaque mètre était
traumatisée par un petit garçon assez
justement son jeu par le soleil noyau
brode ont pas sur une histoire comme ça
et après on brode dessus se souvient
justement comment vous bossez viennent
les idées parce que c'est vous kaki
ouais moi j'écris pas trop j'ai pris pas
trop de fois je me doute deux idées sur
des carnets mais pas grand chose et
c'est en studio que j'ai presque
toujours tout où sa femme sachant sont
d'abord liées au tibet mieux ovale à la
maison
[Musique]
après je vais faut faire des maîtres des
paroles et je suis en studio j'ai des
idées ou pas et après fou voilà des
paroles là dessus ouais d'accord voilà
faut que ça veut dire que c'est bidon et
suce ma roue à la ccit vullien ou pas du
tout vulgaire sur ce magot sont pas
pardon c'est dans le vélo nice à sucer
la roue de quelqu'un c'est quand tu
roules derrière tu prends pas le tu vas
jouer devanture est derrière toi pour
ton activement à la fatigue mans ce soir
avec ce concept afin de le loger le gros
coup quand j'ai le temps
et bien alors justement pourquoi avoir
continué à mener deux carrières de front
après avoir travaillé et la poésie siens
oui l air est épais toujours là possède
trek monde me pose la question mais
parce que parce que j'ai pas envie c'est
pas rigolo si c'est ton métier de faire
de la musique c'est comme tous les
métiers que ce ton métier tout lève le
matin tu bosses tu n'es décaisser le
quartier web si tu gagnes ta vie avec
son épouse pour gagner payer son loyer
tuffreau studio
certes écart ou de cacher je n'ai pas
envie de rentrer là dedans ce parce que
je rende sa liberté jouer sur wii je
peux et chansons que j'ai envie je m'en
fous pas mal me faire virer purée maison
de disque que je m'en fous c'était ça
oui la liberté et à mon travail dans le
lot de potter accepté j'avoue je suis la
liberté pour un diamant les indiens du t
il j'avais une promo j'étais plusieurs
stocks technicien la ratp quand je suis
parti moi je dis je continue sur mon
idée vas-y toi même caractérisée par
cette liberté de parole
voilà chirac en prison le portefeuille
de manu chao
vous osez dire les choses cash pour dire
oui pour les paras qui rit non plus
enfin tu vois où les ou non monsieur
charles et blum et un peu enfin qu' on
est comme on dit nerveux voilà quand
même oui ça dénote bah oui ce que tout
bon bonne tournée mais gilles idier
merci à vous a très vite j'espère c'est
la fin de ce set 8 les invités merci de
nous avoir suivis prochaine édition
demain à la même heure bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]